hey i'm dale this is making with ml and
today i'm going to show you how this
adorable little fox is the future of
video game interactions
[Music]
so imagine you're playing this sick new
game where you decide to visit your
local shopkeeper
but the shopkeeper doesn't have what you
need
what if instead of selecting from a list
you could ask for what you want in plain
english
while the game uses machine learning to
come up with a fitting response
[Music]
or what about making objects like cats
and trees more interactive
action the game developers didn't even
consider
can ml expand the ways players interact
with the game world
today i sat down with anna kipnis a
senior creative technologist here with
stadia games entertainment and we talked
about how machine learning can make game
worlds more interactive
in my lifetime we've seen games go from
very low fidelity like maybe two colors
like pong or something like that to
extremely
realistic 3d so like you know the visual
development of games
has really exploded but i think that the
interactivity um
is still really lagging behind like
we're not that far
from where we started really and so what
i'm really interested in is kind of
um closing that gap why is it so
difficult today to build a game that
supports all of these rich varied and
spontaneous interactions
right now the process is that the
developers have to anticipate
what all the questions that the player
might ask of their world like are they
going to like
ask about this specific weapon or
something like that what should happen
is a response to that right
so right at the moment the the
developers have to account for both the
cool answers that they can have in the
world but also
every single question that the player
might ever have what semantic ml
allows you to do is it allows you as a
developer to focus mainly on the
on the interesting answers the
technology anna is talking about here
semantic ml is a way of making sense of
words or sentences with machine learning
given a set of words you can use a model
to see which pairs are the most similar
for example an ml model can tell you
that a jet pack is more similar to a
flying broomstick than it is to a
garbage can or an apple
you can also use semantic ml to help
pick out likely responses to queries
so if i say i would like some coffee
semantic ml can tell me
here's a cup is a better response than i
hate your butt
anna uses semantic ml to describe her
game worlds in plain english and then
have a model infer how the world should
behave
let's take a look i've labeled objects
uh using english that might be
interesting for the fox to interact with
and in pink you see the sorts of actions
that the fox can do on these objects
it can predict okay of the list that you
just gave me
if this is what the player said or did
it will be able to rank them from best
to worst
in terms of what is the most likely
thing that
somebody in conversation might have done
so uh first um let's say hi to everyone
um it waves and then let's see
if we can uh have some coffee here
so it goes to be so cute
yeah um it brings it to us
and the coolest thing is i didn't
program the fox how to answer
these questions or even you know what
the heck coffee is um i just labeled
that object that kind of looks like a
cup um i put it like a small mug
you know that's just the english words
and semantic ml kind of did everything
else
you can type sentences they don't even
have to be particularly
like spot on right like you can say sofa
and it'll know it's couch
i actually had the system rigged up so
that you can just do them straight up in
google sheets um and then you can
try these really bizarre things like get
really stoked guys get excited cool make
some
money oh whoops the contradicting
because the
type monet instead of money and you know
this thing actually
has cultural associations and so yeah
you know it understands that like monet
is a
painter and so it conjured a painting um
so yeah and so
here now that it's spelled correctly it
creates a coin
what you just showed me it's exactly
what you're saying where like
you as even as the person that built the
demo it's still
surprising and spontaneous to you
exactly this is like
what's what's so magical to me is that
there is like essentially
a way to condense some of these patterns
that people have in conversation
condense all of that human interaction
into like a usable form that you can
have in a game
to me that's like it's essentially
indistinguishable from magic
if you want to learn more about the
tools that anna used to build her demo
and how you can use them make sure you
check out the blog in the link below
and let us know what you build in the
comments see you next time
you